her birthday is uh  December 13th meaning that by the time  she would be inaugurated she would be 35  years old Taylor Swift is going to run  for the Democratic ticket that's it  that's what they're doing that's why AOC  is all over it yeah I think that makes  sense I mean I think she is that  influential among at least young voters  no way maybe I'm wrong what yeah maybe  I'm wrong maybe she's gonna be 34.  she'll be 34 I think  wait wait she's about to turn 33.  so that means she'll be 34 in in 2023  yeah she'll be 35 at the end of 20 uh  2024. so that means she can run because  by the time she's going to be sworn in  she will be old enough to be uh  president 35 right I would do anything  to see a trump Taylor Swift debate oh  man I will sell tickets to that  Ticketmaster can crash okay I'd buy  those ones though like a trump Kanye  ticket versus like a swift Obama